evitar que la competencia se convierta
en el conflicto más temido fue la
premisa del primer cara a cara del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden y
su homólogo chino chilling Pink
creo que el mundo Espera que China y
Estados Unidos desempeña en papeles
clave y aborden los desafíos globales
desde el cambio climático hasta la
alimentación y la seguridad
la situación actual que enfrenta la
relación entre China y Estados Unidos es
una preocupación para todos nosotros
las relaciones entre ambos países están
en uno de sus peores momentos en décadas
por lo que los mandatarios hablaron
durante cerca de tres horas entre los
puntos principales estuvo Taiwán
territorio que Beijing considera una
provincia Rebelde y que ha prometido
reunificar así sea por la fuerza la isla
goza del apoyo económico y militar de
Washington singping avisó a byden de que
no cruce lo que para china es una línea
roja este respondió
[Música]
yo creo que haya un inminente intento de
China de invadir Taiwán
también está la situación en la región
de Asia Pacífico Estados Unidos promete
reforzar su posición en la región si
china no actúa para contener los
programas armamentísticos norcoreanos
mientras que china no esconde su
molestia por la alianza aucus que dotará
de una flota de submarinosa propulsión
nuclear a Australia otro punto de
conflicto es la lucha comercial desde
Estados Unidos piden a sus empresas
reducir su dependencia de China mientras
que desde Beijing protestan por las
restricciones al acceso de productos
tecnológicos la guerra en Ucrania contó
con un punto de consenso
discutimos la agresión de Rusia a
Ucrania y compartimos la misma visión de
que el uso de armas nucleares es
totalmente inaceptable
los dos mandatarios llegan reforzados en
sus países vaiden tras retener el senado
en las elecciones de medio término y
shein Pink tras ser elegido en el
congreso del partido comunista
legitimidad con la que deberán decidir
si reconducir sus relaciones o seguir
por el camino de una peligrosa escalada